Parliament urges EU member-states to  honor their commitment to welcome  160,000 refugees only 11 percent of  these asylum seekers have been relocated  so far MEP s want to start formal  proceedings against hungary by  triggering article 7 of the treaty on  the EU they condemn Budapest for  breaching fundamental rights  nearly half of all Internet users in the  EU stream movies and music or play games  online they should soon have access to  their subscriptions wherever they go  within the EU the UN needs a strong and  united Europe secretary-general Antonio  Guterres told Parliament speaking in the  name of 193 UN member states  MEP call on member states to reduce  their food waste by half by 2030 they  want to grant tax exemptions for food  donations and call for better  information on news on days  [Music]